We searched for
the coolest places in LA
to play ping pong with
portable Pongfinity net
that can turn
almost anything
into an epic
ping pong set up!
The first point,
Santa Monica beach!
The margins are pretty slim!
Noo!
Is that allowed?!
Of course it is!
Next location!
Venice beach skatepark.
Yes, c’mon!
We’re looking for our next spot.
We’re waiting for our quesadillas so let’s play!
You guys are selling these?
Where?
Online?
Online yeah.
We actually have a special campaign for the net
on our webstore,
so go get yourself one of these bad boys!
It’s pretty convenient!
The best thing man!
Oooh!
Did you see that!
Looks like a nice spot.
I’ll get the point for that.
Nice rally!
Nice.
Otto this is pretty challenging!
You think so?
Yes!
I got it thank you!
Okay guys this is the bigger version
of the Pongfinity net,
not yet on sale but maybe one day!
This is the stupidest thing I’ve ever done!
Sorry!
A lot of lucky points there.
Ooh risky!
I'm so confusedy by this place!
Okay Otto I’m not really sure about this one
but let’s try!
In the face!
Ping pong in front of the traditional school buses!
Is that for sale?
Is it on a website?
Yeah yeah there is!
Pongfinity.store
Okay okay okay.
This was a school spot!
For this one we need to get high!
Otto no pressure,
but who ever hits the ball down has to go get it.
Got it!
Winner!
Nice looking scenery.
Come on!
This would be so sick!
This is so risky!
We don’t wanna lose the ball!
Ooh this is intense!
I don’t wanna lose this!
We didn’t lose the ball so I’m happy with that!
Bit of a lucky point.
Oh, okay.
This is a long one.
Yes, come on!
You know where to get yours!
Pongfinity.store
Until next time!
For every net sold this month
We’ll throw in
a free pack of Pongfinity balls.